[Musique]
chaque soir à la résidence brügg garden
ont reproduit l'ambiance d'un souper de
famille les repas sont très importants
pour eux ils sont à table et discutent
déjà de ce qu'ils vont manger ou
prochain repos alors que faire d'abord
la viande pour les protéines
il ne mange pas beaucoup alors leurs
protéines et leurs nutriments doivent
être concentrés afin de leur procurer
assez d'énergie green qui est fier est
établi et contre les croates chez eux et
orge colza il était
kav ici comme dans les écoles que nous
avons visités on applique les nouvelles
règles et tout est bio frais et préparés
maison on s'assure donc que ce soit plus
savoureux oui c'est meilleur des vrais
légumes de 16 ans est meilleur que de
surgelés les gens mangent mieux car la
nourriture savoureuse
ça va dans la bouche au lieu de se
retrouver dans les duels petit thé xx
meilleur coach vous de la purée de
pommes de terre
ja oui et avec de vraies pommes de terre
[Musique]
28 étages 1500 champ un vaste hall
d'entrée magnifiquement décoré un hôtel
non c'est l'hôpital de harlem
[Musique]
chaque matin les chefs se réunissent
pour déguster le repas du midi des
patients potage salade choix de repas et
des cinq ans on est encore temps d'y
apporter des correctifs manquerait de
sel dans les boulettes ainsi que du salé
du beurre dans les patates quant à la
viande ça peut aller et le patient
pourra l'assaisonner si désiré
fricadelle rôti de boeuf aux poires
saucisse pas de complexe ici face à la
viande
il y à de la viande à chaque repas car
les patients ont besoin de protéines
tous les jours
les coûts ont été rationalisées parle
usage de coupe et de viande meilleur
marché fini le veau et vive le pas mais
les bouillouses
on récupère le collier de porc une pièce
souvent négligée et qui se vend en bio
au même prix que le conventionnel
toute la boulangerie se fait sur place
pour travailler en bio on doit tout
faire nous-mêmes à partir de zéro tout
est fait maison
sinon ce serait trop chère à l'achat et
à chaque saison ses fruits et légumes
nous voulons faire une cuisine qui a du
sens pour les patients on mange des
fraises en juillet quand elles sont les
meilleurs alors une tomate d'espagne en
décembre ça ne cadre pas avec nos
objectifs notre amie valérie avait vécu
un vrai choc de cultures en accouchant à
l'hôpital de m
j'étais avec ma mère m'ont dit mais tu
es vraiment une personne qui est en
train de se remettre mieux donc ton
repas offert par titre
[Musique]
cet ex footballeur professionnel blessé
au pied a passé plusieurs semaines ici
suite à une chirurgie tention avec le
groupe et mitch péché de ce fait les
réformes et les protéines dragon warrior
et mitch au fil de votre récente série
de pubs aux familles de titres ou de le
déborder le vote de cette loi peut aller
à la cafétéria à l'hôpital y ont une
place au départ et manger et ils vont te
forcer surtout après avoir eu un enfant
ils vont forcer le premier 24 heures oui
tu peux me rend vachement bien passé
l'an dernier
ça fait partie aussi la sociabilité lie
tout le monde s'asseoir ensemble ça fait
partie du repas allez hop
avertissements la description du désir
du jour pourrait vous donner envie
d'être passive mousse infusé au fond est
grillé gelée de rhubarbe et camomille
combo de pain de seigle récupérer
noisette cassonade beurre et bien et
garnitures de fraises et de framboises
lyophilisés
just bossé très très bon très bon messi